shadow of the Tomb Raider is the third
game in the reboot game series that
follows Lara Croft on her journey to
become a legend like most games in the
series there's a lot to unpack from both
the ending and its post-credit scene and
throughout this video I'll be discussing
the plot in full detail there will be
heavy spoilers and in my opinion this
game is definitely worth playing through
if you're a fan so make sure you come
back to this video I'll lay a day if you
yet to complete the storyline with that
out the way I'm definition and I ruin
the game so you don't have to by the end
of shadow of the Tomb Raider Lara is in
a dire situation she's killed loads of
people she's jumped on hundreds of
clearly marked ledges and has maintained
her best Nathan Drake impression for 20
hours but she's still in trouble the
order of the Trinity has obtained both
key items and is now free to control the
Mayan apocalypse and use it to reshape
the world in their image enemy of fun
Lara Croft for some reason doesn't want
the world to be enslaved by a group of
madmen no she's perfectly content with
Donald Trump Theresa May and the lot
ruling the world already her Trinity are
just gonna go too far in the final
showdown
Lara manages to kill the antagonist
Dominique wears and in doing so manages
to not only save the world but to avenge
her father's death
in his dying breath Dominique wears I
don't know how to pronounce it passes
the key of chap shell on to Lara
which transfers the powers to her due to
this Lara has the ability to change the
world as she sees fit what I thought we
would get a world of clearly marked
Ledger's and no more Uncharted games how
did that joke again instead we get a
vision of her tragic past replaced with
a happy childhood
Lara ever the good guy turns away from
this fantasy however which is when she's
faced with crimson fire crimson fire
wants to stop the apocalypse that has
been brought forward by Trinity and in
order to power the Sun they need to kill
a god
this puts Lara directly in the firing
line
but she's more than willing to go
sacrifice herself even if it means a
game over screen with no continues
crimson fire goes forward to take the
power they thrust down with the dagger
stopping just above Lara's chest which
draws the light from her the Eclipse
ends as we see the screen fades away and
we flash-forward to two days later you
ran at two's funeral I just can't get
these names Jonah and Lara decide to go
their separate ways and the to depart
Lara decides the saying help the locals
whilst Jonah pursues his love interest
Abbie probably because after 10 years he
finally realizes he's getting nowhere
with Laura as she's a bit of a sourpuss
and he's been well and truly
friend-zoned don't worry though the game
isn't over yet and during the credits we
are treated to a scene which ties a nice
bow on the trilogy as a whole we join
Lara in Croft Manor as she writes a
letter to Jonah
this shows that Lara has finally
accepted her father's passing as the
family home was often a place that she
avoided wherever possible
the room is awash with trophies from the
past three games as well as a little nod
to the original ps1 game in the form of
a child's drawing of a dinosaur there
the callbacks are introduced when we get
a glimpse of Lara's Butler for the first
time in the series he's visibly shaking
which is of course one of his key
characteristics and something that
carries over from Tomb Raider to you I
used to spend hours locking him in that
giant freezer and maybe if Lara had have
done this in her childhood she would be
as happy as I am but she didn't did she
and that's why this series was reported
any way now Lara seems content and happy
for the first time and it's a great
closer that tops off this astounding
trilogy where it will journey in the
future is unknown but it's still the
perfect ending point for the origin
story of Lara Croft so what did you
think of shadow of the Tomb Raider do
you think it topped off the trilogy well
and what would you like to see in future
installments do you want a game where
you just lock the butler in the freezer
over and over cuz I do anyway comment
below and let me know and if you enjoy
this video then please like it and
subscribe to my channel I create content
like this weekly and they'll definitely
be something on here that you
love if you're a fan of games recently I
discussed the ending of God of War so
make sure you check that video next
linked at the end of this one thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
you